Alright, let's look at the second approach. And again,
this is the approach to book takes to solve
this particular problem.
And here we are first going to calculate the posterior
likelihood.
And then we will find.
the posterior probability
in the first approach we found the we found
the positive probability. That was our attention from the
start.
Here, however, we're going to first calculate the posterior likelihood.
If you remember.
We said that odds and likelihood are
both ratios.
Where we are comparing one event.
against another
so likelihood is not a probabilistic number. It
is not a number between 0 and 1.
or as probability is
So first, we will find this likelihood.
Which can either be a very small or big number?
greater than one or below 1
and then we'll see how we can turn it to probability. So we're
going to go likelihood and then probability.
And then there's something you also need to know about the relationship.
between probability and likelihood
the posterior probability
Is proportional to the odds ratio and the
likelihood ratio? Let me say this again.
posterior likelihood
which is not a
Probabilistic number it is not a number between 0 and 1.
Is equal to the odds ratio times the likelihood
ratio. So again, you're not going to get a probability from
this expression.
You will see what the odds ratio are likelihood ratios are in a
second.
However, the posterior probability.
which
is a number between zero one is proportional this
symbol.
Is called the proportional symbol it's proportional to
the product of the odds ratio and the likelihood ratio meaning if
this grows.
This will grow with it proportionally.
If this shrinks this will shrink with
it proportionally.
Okay, it's a good idea to know this because you might come across
these terms or this.
form of expressing their Bayesian theorem
in
other places
so let's first find out what the likelihood is and to do
this we must first.
Find the ratio for the odds and then the ratio
for the likelihood.
Now art is a ratio. So it's kind of
redundant to say odds ratio, but I'm just doing this for extra emphasis.
So the odds
ratio
Is well?
the probability of one event versus another
Here we want to know. What is the probability of being guilty?
Over the probability of being innocent a guilty hypothesis
over an innocent hypothesis.
Now if you look up that table we had from before.
You will see where these numbers are coming from.
20 out of the 1,000 athletes tested positively 980 tested
negatively.
Irrespective of whether they are actually guilty or
not.
and it comes down to this and if
we evaluate this we can
we get 1 over 49.
So this is the odds ratio.
the likelihood ratio
will be this.
The probability of testing positively given the athlete
is guilty over the pause the probability of
testing positively given the athletes innocent.
to find out what this part what these two
probably these are
we will do it like so
since this is conditional probability. We
know that we can express it like so we can express it like
so
And since we already evaluated the joint
and marginal probabilities, we can just plug in these values.
And you will get 95%
and this is consistent.
With what? We already know about the exercise.
Now probably of testing positively is 95%
whether you're actually I mean whether you're guilty or not.
The screening test will have a 95%
Accuracy, so the probability of it being accurate is
95% So this
You know.
It's consistent what what we were given about the
exercise.
similarly
the probability of testing positively when the athletes innocent
is 5%
and again this adds up.
but now if we were to put these two probabilities
Into a ratio which we now call the
likelihood ratio.
So we'll be 0.95 or a point zero five 95% over
5% We will get 19.
Now just for convenience for the
next step. I ever expressed 19
as 19 over 1. This is just 19 because
once we multiply odds
and likelihood I want
the notation to be
You know nice and tidy.
Otherwise, there's no reason for me to put one in the denominator.
This isn't actually change the value.
Now if you look at if we interprets in
a different way.
It tells us that one out of every 19 athletes one
out of every 19.
athletes
Who are accused of doping?
Are actually innocent.
One out of 19 athletes who are accused of being
guilty.
Are actually unison.
So, what does that tell us about this?
test
so even though even though the odds are in favor of the athlete
being innocent
the likelihood says that one out of 19 athletes.
Who are accused of doping are going to be innocent?
so
to answer the question.
That was first pose by this exercise. Let's actually take
the product.
Of the Arts and the likelihood that's the posterior.
So again the posterior likelihood that's the likelihood
still.
Is the product of the likelihood and the odds just for
emphasis? Let me put here the word likelihood.
Okay, so the posterior likelihood is a product of likelihood and
ratio.
and if you multiply these two fractions
We'll get 19 over 49.
Now this is still not 28%
and that's because this is not a probability.
To turn this into a probability.
What we have to do is this now by the way 49.
49 let me pull up that figure.
49 is the number of athletes.
Who tested positively but they are not doping.
In order for us to turn this probability in order
for us to turn this likelihood into a probability.
we must
Also take into account the number of athletes who
are doping who tested positively
and they are doing so we have to add up these two
numbers in the denominator and that's what we're doing over here.
So we have the number of athletes.
Who tested positively and they are doping over?
The number of athletes who tested positively and they are
doping and the number of athletes who tested positively and they
are not doping.
That gives us 19 over 68 and once
again we arrive.
at 28%
now you may have a preference for one or the other.
One of the approaches we looked at.
But again, you are going to
come across different ways of using the Bayesian
theorem.
So the Bayesian theorem is not limited to a fixed algebraic expression.
It's this concept.
That we can associate.
prior information
a likelihood information
to arrive at to arrive at a new assumption